[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM MICHELSON:
Thank you everybody
for attending this session.
This is the best
venue I've ever had
an opportunity to
present anything in,
so I'm going to enjoy that.
And for the folks who may be
looking at it on the stream
afterwards, we're
in an IMAX theater.
So if I try to make a few
movie jokes, that's why.
So this session, again, thank
you very much for joining us.
The conversation for today
is around Internet of Things
and how to find ROI,
return on investment.
Hopefully the folks in this room
have experienced some of IoT.
But it's around the
Internet of Things,
connecting things
to the internet.
And within IoT, there is a
couple of different angles.
One is technical.
We hear a lot about
IoT technologies--
MQTT, and TLS, and lots
of three-letter acronyms.
And that is important.
But there's a whole
other side of it,
which is IoT's not
just a technology,
but it's a whole new
business venture.
I don't know about
the folks in the room,
but I haven't met my
first chief IoT officer.
So IoT is still very new.
And many enterprises
are trying to figure out
how it fits into their
organization as part of that.
And one key aspect of it is ROI.
Where is the money
in this stuff?
And a lot of the companies that
we work with and that we see
are trying to figure that out.
So, quick introductions,
and we'll dive right in.
So I'm Adam Michelson.
And I'm a product manager
inside of Google IoT Core,
which is Google's IoT offering.
So my job is to build
some of that tech
to make sure IoT
products are safe,
and secure, reliable,
low latency,
but also hopefully
build a product
that folks in the enterprise
can drive real value from.
And frankly that's
as much if not
more challenging than
building a technical product
with low latency
and high security.
So before we dive right in.
I want to do the
other introductions
of the guests who
are joining us,
which I'm super excited about.
So when I learned
about this session
and that Phil and Doug
would be joining us,
it was an honor because
it's so exciting
to see when IoT's
being used in the field
and have customers and
actual users come forward
and offer us their
advice around what's
working with IoT from a money
perspective and what's not.
And that's what Phil and
Doug are here to talk about.
I'll give the mic over to
them in a second to introduce.
But as a quick introduction,
so Doug Standley,
he's a partner of Google.
And he has a company
called niolabs
that specializes in
building IoT solutions
and has an IoT product
to help customers.
And then Phil Asmundson he
owns a winery, very cool.
And he's in
agriculture business.
So it's Phil's job to
figure out is IoT worth it?
And is there ROI in it?
So to have these
folks here today
just to share their experience
is an honor for myself
to present with.
So Doug, Phil can you
introduce yourselves?
DOUG STANDLEY: Hi,
I'm Doug Standley.
Are we live?
ADAM MICHELSON: [INAUDIBLE]
DOUG STANDLEY: Hi,
I'm Doug Standley.
I'm the CEO and
co-founder of niolabs.
It's really a pleasure to be
here on behalf of our team.
We're very, very
excited to actually
share with you a real
IoT implementation that
is getting real results.
We were recently with Google
at IoT World in their booth.
And the overwhelming reaction
we got was, is this really real?
And so I think that
was my takeaway
around the state of the market.
And so we're excited today
and not only share the tech
but the results of
something very real.
Phil?
PHIL ASMUNDSON: Hi.
I'm Phil Asmundson.
And along with my
wife, Kim, we're
the owners of Deep Sky Vineyard.
And Adam said, do
you want to tell you
a little bit about
how IoT and ROI might
come from that in the field.
In this case, it
literally is in a field.
I am not a long-time wine
guy except for enjoying it.
But until four years ago,
I was a vice chairman
and led our technology media and
telecom practice at Deloitte.
So I come from a
tech background.
So it was very easy for
me to get into this.
And I'm excited to
share what we've
learned at Deep Sky Vineyard.
ADAM MICHELSON: Awesome.
Thank you.
So as we dive in,
so quick survey.
So when it comes to IoT
and in the audience here,
just a quick raise of hands
in terms of how many folks
are experimenting with
IoT in their organization,
which is like
somebody, somewhere
has a Raspberry Pi doing
something, or an Arduino,
or an Android Things connecting?
Great.
It looks like the vast majority.
We see that as well.
And there's ages of IoT.
We're still very much
at the dawn of IoT.
So I think we're all
together in this journey
to figure out how IoT functions.
But we do see a lot of folks
who want to experience with IoT
have connected something.
So it's like the
connectivity age maybe
we're in the middle of or maybe
at the end of in terms of,
can I just get a
device connected?
So, the next question is around
how many folks in the audience
have full-blown IoT products
supported in the field
with customers using
it, your call center
can answer questions, your
documentation warranty
is out there, how many
of the folks have that?
Less, which is what we expect.
So that's a lot of
the things that we
want to talk about
today is that gap.
IoT is new.
So we don't expect a
lot of IoT products
that are fully out
there in the field.
But there is a
pretty dramatic gap
that sitting in between
the amount of projects
being piloted and the amount
of projects in the field.
So there's a term that's
being thrown about.
I look at it with whimsy,
which is "pilot purgatory."
if you Google it--
it's a generic term.
But it's very much being
associated with IoT.
And what it means is
we started a project,
we haven't finished it.
We're trying to figure out how
does the connectivity work?
How do all these
components come together?
And how does it exactly
provide business value
for my boss, my shareholders, my
university, whatever it may be?
So this concept of
pilot purgatory I think
is very relevant
when it comes to ROI.
One thing that
we're seeing is what
is one of the major
challenges around why
products and projects get
stuck in pilot purgatory?
So this is just a
study by McKinsey.
There's many such
studies that are similar.
But this is a good
one to take it
as an example, which is around
84% of the companies that
started a pilot are
still in it a year later.
That's a lot.
And IoT is new.
And the promise of IoT is great.
So our bosses allow us some
flexibility to run pilots.
But a year's a long time 30% are
still in a pilot two years in.
And around 30% of projects
have gone to production.
So 70% of the projects
haven't even exited pilot.
So there's something here
holding projects back.
According to this study,
the top three factors
are executive support, so
whatever keeps the CEO up
at night, is IoT solving it?
Maybe not, strong
business case and also
strong internal
organizational alignment.
So I think what's
interesting here is these
are not technical challenges.
These are business challenges.
So the thesis is that
many of the reasons we're
stuck in pilot
purgatory isn't just
all the technology is
getting woven together.
It's how do we establish ROI?
And what's a methodology to
find the revenue inside of IoT?
So, why and how?
Certainly the how of IoT is
super interesting, certainly
for geeks like me.
Like connecting all
this stuff, here's
an example of some underwater
technology, underwater cameras
that Google has that we
partner up with [? Katelyn. ?]
And that's what's powering
underwater Street View.
So if you google
Underwater Street View,
you can explore the Great
Barrier Reef, very cool.
If you're building
a device like this,
then I recommend we
spend a lot of time
technically proving this.
How does a device
work underwater?
How does Wi-Fi work underwater?
It sounds like a Google
interview question now
that I think of it.
I have I actually have no idea.
So, if this is what
you're dealing with,
then spend a lot of time
with technology inside
of your pilots.
If it's not, then the
suggestion is that we
should trust our devices.
We will get them connected.
Very rarely do we see
a device that can't be.
The challenge is there's a lot
of IoT technology out there.
So how do I get the
right security protocols,
the right conductivity
protocols,
keep it secure, create
a device registry?
Basically, it's an
assembly challenge
of getting the right
components assembled
to create an IoT solution.
But we should all have
faith, for the most
part, that the device
will be connected.
But the challenge
is really the why.
If we spend a lot of our
time, 80% of our effort,
on the how, and that's
what our labs look
like, and maybe 20% on the why,
we're stuck in pilot purgatory.
We need to balance
that out a bit.
So what we've done is worked
with a number of customers
to come up with a framework
that is pretty simple where
we can discover the why.
Where is the ROI?
And that's what I want
to present right now.
So this is one of the
key slides that we
show some customers
and prospects
and walk them through.
So there's direct ROI.
It's the best type.
So I did this IoT project,
and because of it, I
derived actual value.
So when it comes to
direct ROI, there's
a couple of sides in
the balance sheet.
Simple, right?
I can sell more.
I can save.
One way to sell more
is feature enablement.
It's a cooler product.
So if you think of
B2C, or even B2B,
if I have a product
that has IoT capability,
it has more features.
Because of that,
people may buy it.
It's also a great
reason to refresh,
so upgrade to the IoT
product versus the one that
wasn't, which is great.
All revenue is good revenue.
The problem here is it's
a one-time purchase.
And every time we IoT enable the
device, the cost of that device
goes up because we have to pay
to keep that device connected.
What we've seen is that device
can cost anywhere from $0.25
a year to $1 a more a
year to get connected.
That increases your
bill of materials.
And if your margins are
high on your products,
and your lifespan is relatively
low on your products, maybe
five to 10 years, you may
be able to absorb the bill
of materials difference.
But very few companies
that we deal with can.
It's a competitive market.
So what other
techniques do we have
to generate revenue beyond
just the individual sales?
Some of these other categories,
so sales enablement.
And what we're talking about
here is replenishables.
It's the razor and blades story.
So I'll give you the razor for
free if you'll buy my blades.
So from a replenishable
perspective,
if we can create a product where
we can identify that something
has been consumed,
create a subscription,
automatically send
it to you, we can
create a subscription model.
And that's the nirvana of ROI.
The next one down is
service enablement.
And here you think of like
anything as a service.
If you want to be cool
at an IoT cocktail party
say, something as a service.
So the idea is I am
an HVAC provider.
But since I know the air
quality of the indoor building,
I'll sell you air
quality as a service.
And the better quality you
want, the more you'll pay me.
And then I'll figure
out when to switch out
all the various filters.
So that's service enablement.
And then the next is
scale and pricing,
which is that if you become
operationally efficient enough,
then sometimes you can
actually produce more product
than you used to be able to and
maybe even charge a premium.
So it's just another
avenue to achieve money.
On the right-hand side
are around efficiencies.
Think of a warehouse.
So increase up time,
I added one more nine
to my number of nines on
my manufacturing floor.
Or you lowered risk
for your employees
by IoT-enabling equipment
and make sure nothing hits
somebody.
Resource efficiency,
certainly, to make sure
that you're consuming your
resources effectively and then
have a higher quality product.
So you may think a more
based on your vertical.
But these ones we've
seen work again and again
for 80% of the businesses we
work with, so direct revenue.
Now we see all this
indirect revenue.
So this is a
blessing and a curse.
This indirect revenue
is the promise of IoT.
It's where phrases like "data
is the new oil" comes from,
or big data, and data science.
And the idea is you collect--
you sensor all your
data, put sensors on it,
collect lots of data, and then
money comes out the other side,
except very rarely
does that happen.
These indirect revenue
impacts are meaningful.
But if all of our business
cases are based on them,
then we can definitely get
stuck in pilot purgatory
because we're looking
for long-term money that
is a little hard to connect.
So to go around the wheel really
quickly in the upper right,
targeted marketing.
The idea is that
a manufacturer who
makes whatever, a
dishwasher, now I
get to know my customer better
through IoT, and because
of that, because
I know my customer
and my customer
segment, I can market
to them more effectively.
Building better products,
I see how customers
are using my products.
Therefore, my next rev is going
to be of a higher quality.
And enhanced brand, I guess the
marketers could debate this.
But in B2C anyway,
when I put IoT-enabled
the brand becomes
a little cooler.
A little blue light shows up,
and it's you're a cooler brand.
New business services.
So we've seen customers who
are in the electrical business.
They'll make a surge suppressor.
And now what they can see
is there's been a surge,
maybe some of the
equipment is out.
So what they can do is
join the gig economy
and have electricians
who are roaming around
give the deal to them
to go and fix the job.
So I used to be a
manufacturer, and now I'm
participating in the gig
economy, a brand new business
opportunity.
And then customer
engagement, this
is where a customer calls
in your call center.
Now you can see their device.
Most manufacturers who
are participating in IoT
know the customer basically
through a warranty card.
But now through IoT in an app, I
can know the customer directly.
That's a responsibility.
But it's also an
opportunity to increase
my NPS, my net promoter
scores because I
can service the customer.
I can get a first time fix.
So all these are great.
What we see as we go around the
horn here, work with customers,
and say, check off as
many of these as you can,
to say how you're
going to generate ROI.
And what we'd love to
see is in early pilots--
so many of us are in pilots.
We just like a raise of hands.
Try to get as much direct
revenue as possible
because you can prove to
your business in a short term
that this is valuable.
And then around the outside,
the indirect revenue, maybe
even larger opportunities.
But those will come second
once you have more time,
rolled out a larger pilot,
collected more data,
and had the opportunity
to mine that data.
The more checkmarks
the better, it's
just a little bit
of a warning sign
if they're all on the outside.
So what I want to do now is
pull in Doug and pull in Phil
and have them walk you through
the specific agriculture
example.
What do they find on this?
What were the bets
that they were
placing at the beginning
of their project?
What was the reality
of what they found?
And how can we all learn
from their mistakes--
that's what we want to do--
as well as what they
accomplished and then
apply that, obviously,
to the folks in the room.
So Doug, Phil.
DOUG STANDLEY: Thank you, Adam.
And so just to keep
this framework in mind,
we are able to look back
at the Deep Sky project,
we're in our third year--
actually we're in our fourth
year--
and-- no, third year, sorry.
I'm already thinking
about next year--
and have a really accurate view
of did we achieve our goals?
Make no mistake--
Phil has mentioned that he
was a former Deloitte partner.
I, too, am a former
Deloitte partner--
we knew how to do business case.
And we certainly
know how to do ROI.
We think these frameworks
are very solid tools.
And frankly, we follow
the methodology.
We didn't make decision to
move forward in Deep Sky
until we had collective
alignment between our customer,
the Asmundsons, and Deep
Sky Vineyard, and our team.
And fortunately, which
we'll share with you,
we'll go on a granular level on
the results a little bit later.
But as you look at the wheel of
fortune here of ROI benefits,
we really hit the
ball out of the park.
And again, I'm excited to
share with direct as well
as the intangible items.
And you'll hear about
Phil talking about some
of the strategic bets
they're making now
because of these frankly
longer-term benefits.
But first of it does
me a little bit,
niolabs is not an
ag tech company.
That's the first thing I
think that surprises people.
Truth be told, we decided
to connect this vineyard
because of a
screaming phone call
I received from a former
partner at Deloitte.
The outrage of him
watching his wife
get up and drive two hours
to their Vineyard just
to see if the water
was turned on.
And so that started
the conversation.
We had a big pain point
from the customer.
To our surprise, it was an
amazing qualifying application
for us for our platform.
We still operate in a
horizontal business model.
And we have lots
of demand for ag.
Our preference is to be
that horizontal platform
and partner with others.
So, let me take you through a
little bit of the experience
of Deep Sky Vineyard.
This is about two minutes long.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SOFT, MELLOW MUSIC PLAYING]
- Farming, it's the
oldest industry on earth
and arguably the most important.
It feeds the world, employs
millions, sustains life.
And it's under siege.
Agriculture consumes 70% of
the world's water, its most
precious resource.
A single almond the
size of a thumbprint
requires just over a
gallon to reach maturity.
Put another way, that
water that California
uses in a single year
just to grow almonds
is enough to serve all
the homes and businesses
in the Greater Los Angeles
area for nearly three years.
Farmers rely on diverse data
and generations of accumulated
experience to do what they do.
But farming is still farming.
And operating margins are slim.
The oldest industry
on earth also
has the oldest challenge--
consume less, produce.
The data that empowers
21st century farming
pours in from
sensors in the ground
that measure moisture
content from water volume
monitors deep in the aquifer,
from weather stations,
and from generations of
experience and knowledge.
But here's the challenge.
How can all that data become
a single, meaningful real-time
indicator of how
the crop is doing?
Well, there is a solution.
Imagine that you're a vineyard
operator with the ability
to log into a mobile app
to see contextualized data
from thousands of sensors
telling you everything that's
happening in your
vineyard, in real time,
from anywhere in the world.
That same app helps you
anticipate and respond
to equipment before they
occur through rich, predictive
insight and provides
detailed information
about the vineyard's
micro climate.
Imagine receiving requests for
water directly from the plants
and having a system that
can automatically respond,
or being able to
focus specifically
on one row of vines or on
the data from a single plant.
Imagine being able
to view and analyze
the color of the
grapes on that plant
or the ratio of the
sun above the canopy
to the shade below it.
This Is precision agriculture.
This is nio.
We combine millions of
unrelated, complex data points
and convert them into a simple,
visual, richly insightful
experience.
And the result, lower cost in
resource consumption, higher
crop yields, and
better product quality.
Precision agriculture is a
game changer for farming.
When experience combines
with real time data collected
at the plants themselves, we
redefine the world's oldest
and most revered industry.
And that is only the beginning.
[END PLAYBACK]
DOUG STANDLEY: We are
outrageously proud of the work
we've done a Deep Sky Vineyard.
But we're also a
pragmatist about this.
And the partnership
that we've formed
with Google now has us, frankly,
were reciting the Google terms.
We think about
precision agriculture.
Is it scalable for the planet?
As you're developing a
use case for ROI for IoT,
one thing that
people tend to forget
is number one, as Adam
mentioned, they focus
really too much on the how.
And a big lesson we learned,
man, we really overworked this.
We did everything in this
vineyard as Phil could attest.
We built the boxes.
We built to specs.
We dug the trenches.
We augured the holes.
We did every single
aspect of it.
Initially, we wanted to know
the challenges that our platform
users would face when they took
our product into the market.
But frankly, we
really overdid it.
So I would tell you
focusing on the why,
we did a great job of that.
But think about the
macroeconomic opportunities
that IoT can unlock.
The reality today
is our farmable land
has decreased by 40%.
By 2050, we have to increase
our food production by 70%.
Today nobody is pining to go
into farming where there's
a massive labor shortage.
I won't get political I promise.
And then lastly,
farming consumes
70% of the fresh
water on our planet.
And it's trending
towards 80% or 90%.
Now the big bomb that
we all need to consider
is it's a known fact that 60%
of the water used in farming
is wasted.
Now later, we're going to get
into a granular experience
of Deep Sky Vineyard.
And frankly, the stats add up.
So, now we're going to actually
take you into the vineyard.
In our limited time here,
one morning I have you,
you can go in-- and
it's a real time
experience from
the niolab website,
or you can go to our booth.
And I want to get pitchy.
But you can look at Deep
Sky Vineyard in real time
any time you want.
Phillip's not going to let
you control his vineyard.
And he's not going to
disclose his private reporting
tab that I'm not going
to expose to you here.
But let me do that.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: There we go.
Well that's it.
We're done.
DOUG STANDLEY: Check,
check, check, check.
Bare with me one second,
technical problem.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: Oh,
here comes the man.
DOUG STANDLEY: Good grief,
worked so great in our warm up.
SPEAKER: It's the demo gods.
DOUG STANDLEY: The demo gods.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: While
we're waiting to do that,
let me just give you a little
bit more history on Deep Sky
itself and how a guy with
34 years at Deloitte,
a senior partner
there, a vice chairman,
ended up scratching dirt.
For my 50th birthday,
my wife decided
to take me down to Argentina.
We had a hell of a lot of fun.
In fact, so much fun that
instead of buying a shirt,
we bought a vineyard.
And came home, 27-page
document in Spanish.
Sure enough, I
had it translated.
We had bought a vineyard.
It's a condominium vineyard,
but a vineyard just the same.
Around the same time, we
were moving out to Arizona
from Connecticut.
And while we were out
there driving around,
I happened to comment to
her how much it reminded me
of Mendoza, Argentina.
So she decided to go out
and check around if there
was a wine industry there.
And sure enough, there was.
And about six months later,
I got a text that said, hey,
I bought 20 acres of land
down in Wilcox, Arizona.
We're going to plant a vineyard.
That's literally how
we got here today.
At that point in time, to put--
certainly my wife, who's
done a fabulous job with this
into perspective--
we have no live plants
in our house at all.
They're all dead.
So we had to replace them
all with silk plants.
And so I had to ask her,
I said, what in God's name
makes you think
you can grow vines?
Suffice it to say, that was the
battle cry of challenge to her.
And she has done
a magnificent job.
And it has really
done wonders over--
planted it in 2011,
so through today,
it has made tremendous strides.
And this is a
culmination of what
we wanted to do to really make
sure we were growing the best
grapes possible because
in Arizona, nobody
knows the answer to that yet.
It's very much like
our name, Deep Sky.
It's exploration.
There is no right or wrong.
Nobody has the magic formula.
Nio is helping us
find those formulas.
DOUG STANDLEY: So
what I'll do is
I'm going to just drop
you through a little bit
of the user experience and then
frankly turn it over to Phil.
And he'll tell me
where to navigate.
And he'll take you
through how he uses
the platform on a daily basis.
So we start obviously with
the proverbial dashboard view,
which he takes a glance at.
He peeks at his irrigation.
We have multiple ways of
capturing the weather--
macro and all the way
down to micro, even down
to leaf moisture.
The interesting thing about
farming, your macro forecast,
your weather men can tell
you it's raining like hell,
and you don't get an
iota of water in a farm.
Or it could rain in one block of
a vineyard and not in another.
But more importantly,
if it's windy,
you won't absorb
any of that wine.
So we have multiple
sensory capability
down to even a weather
station on site
as well as within the rows.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: And just to
reemphasize, this is live.
So it is 101 degrees
down there right now.
DOUG STANDLEY: Right now.
He takes a look at the
equipment diagnostics on pumps.
Nio is fully instrumented
throughout that factory,
so well all the way
through a pressure
and flow throughout
various sensors.
He has the ability to add
observations from the vineyard.
This is something I'll
expound on a little bit later.
He looks at the events
of the vineyard.
And lastly, I'll spend a
little bit of time on this.
It's certainly squint print.
You can see it for yourself.
But system view,
these are streaming
perspective of what's
happening in the vineyard
all the time by block.
It's really a
powerful diagnostic.
One thing that I learned
many years ago, fakery
will only get you so
far in innovations.
So everything you're
looking at here
is real, and fortunately
for us, that the Asmundsons
allow us to expose it to the
world, frankly real time.
Phil, so let's walk
us through a day.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: OK.
For me, the dashboard-- go
down to weather real quickly.
There's a couple
other things here,
daily ET, that down here and
up there on the right side.
No, the two inches,
you'll see daily ET.
That's really a measure of
how much water the plants
are basically expiring
to cool themselves down.
That's what they use water for.
It brings nutrients up.
But they're also using
it to cool it down.
So looking at those
forecasts, GDD is degree days.
You need a certain number
of growing degree days
in order to get your fruit ripe.
And so we actually
track that so that we
know about how far we might be
from harvest because we have
that history from year to year.
So there's more there than
just might meet the eye.
That UV index is very important.
That UV index is an
indicator of how much warmer
that fruit will be
if it's in the sun,
if it's in the direct
rays of the sun.
You don't want that fruit
to warm up too much.
Fortunately, we have a
good canopy to shield that.
But let's go on
to the irrigation.
This is where the
real stuff starts.
And to set this up, Doug
mentioned the 100-mile drive,
two-hour trip to get down there.
And having the ability to see
remotely into this vineyard
was very much a driver.
And that was the start of it.
But it really got
its start when I
watched my wife and her
vineyard consultant sit there
and auger hole after hole.
Now, this is a big hand auger.
It drills down about three feet.
She pulls it up, and
there's a big clump
of dirt in the little
cylinder there,
and they drop it
into their hands,
and they start squeezing it,
and they yell out, 55%, 60%.
And I just looked at them and
I said, what the hell are you
doing?
And they told me they're
checking for soil moisture.
And I just decided it
had to be a better way.
And in my vision as
I thought about this,
I could see what was
happening up above the ground
to the plant.
I wanted to see into the ground.
What was happening to the
water when it went in?
And what was happening to
the water when it went out?
And that's really what
this section's all about
So why don't you click on--
just as a general
orientation, the top
is what we're irrigating,
this little map.
Right there, the
brown part over here
is really a map of the vineyard.
Those are all the zones.
Oh, what did you do, Doug?
We just disintegrated
the vineyard.
DOUG STANDLEY: It just
decided to get diverted again.
Help!
Tim will help.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: But
seeing in the ground's
important because nobody
really knows what to do.
You don't know what happens
when it's 101 degrees out.
And if you ask 10 vineyard
operators down there,
you'll get 10 totally
different answers
as to what the right way
to treat your vines are.
And for the most
part, people just
said, put 20 gallons of water
on per vine every five days
and just do that.
But the fact of the matter
is, soil is all different.
And you're going
to see that here.
So there's our map.
We've got another little chart.
OK, so you've gone into five.
That's fine.
Let's just go
there for a minute.
So this is where it
all comes together.
Let's go back to five Doug.
That's five.
You'll see at the top that 100.8
degrees, that's that 101 you
saw before.
You'll see a recommended
gallons of 11.
That's actually what
we're putting on.
If we went back up at
the irrigation screen,
you'll see that five is
scheduled to be watered today
for 11 gallons.
You'll see something called
available water, 54.6%,
and field capacity, 84%.
I'll go a little
into field capacity.
I'll try to stay away from
available water content
except to just give you
an idea of what it is.
Why don't you scroll down, Doug.
And we'll get into the
zone five sensor five area.
The numbers on the left-hand
side of that chart over here
and the numbers of
the left are actually
the current soil
moisture percentages
at each of those depths.
Those depths are 4, 8,
16, 24, 32, and 40 inches.
The number next to that
is the degree of the soil.
So as you would expect, it
gets cooler as it goes down.
It's going to be
warmest up at the top
and get cooler going down.
Those are more
important to us when
we're approaching bud break,
when the plant actually
comes back up and you start
to see green because there's
certain temperatures for
different varietals, that
will indicate when
that's about to happen.
So not quite as important
because remember, this is now.
This is during veraison.
And if nobody knows
what veraison is,
it means when these hard,
green berries start to soften.
And in the case of red
grapes, they turn red.
In the case of
white wine grapes,
they turn golden in color.
So this is the
start, the prequel
to the actual ripening process
different during harvest.
Those buttons in the middle,
the two that are green,
are green because
right now those
are our zones of interest.
We want to try to make pure
water gets to those zones
because those numbers over
there on the right-hand side
is the percent of water
that is being taken up
at each of those depths.
So let's just think
about that for a moment.
So what I know, I
said I want to be
able to look into the ground.
I not only watch the water as
it goes down into the ground,
but I watch it as it comes out.
And if you could just
click on-- why don't you
click on the 11-gallon
per vine irrigation
up there on this left
side, Doug, 7-12.
Oh, that's the 10.
Go down to 11 if you could.
He was always a great partner.
But he did not listen very well.
DOUG STANDLEY: Where do
you want me at, Phil?
PHIL ASMUNDSON: The 11
gallon one, go down 7-12.
There you go.
DOUG STANDLEY: There we go.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: So
you got to look up
a little bit on this one.
But what you see is this tells
me what the starting and soil
moisture percentages were,
what the ending ones were.
And then what this
plus 24 is, this
is important the way
water dynamics work.
And believe it or
not, it's incredibly
consistent from
irrigation to irrigation.
If you look all the
way over to the left,
you'll see something called
Observed FC, or field capacity.
Think of that as
the glass is full.
That's the point at which
the soil can hold the water
against the force of gravity.
And you really find that out
not when the irrigation is
done because you'll
see those numbers
are higher than the 24 ones.
And what they're
doing is they're
coming back down
to field capacity
in about 24 hours later.
It's at that point
that I start capturing
how much water the vines
are pulling from each depth.
And if you follow across,
I think it's 66.73 and 67--
I'll see it better down here--
and 66 to 66.39.
That'll almost be the exact
same thing all the time.
So that's why when
I'm looking at this,
and I'm trying to figure
out what I want to do,
I actually went in and looked
at that 11-gallon per vine
watering to see what happened.
And that's the
one I chose to do.
Now, you'll see that if
you went down to 15--
go down to the 15 on,
7-17 for a moment,
just to show a difference--
7-7, sorry.
Down, there you go, right there.
You can see we practiced this
a lot, which we did, actually.
What you'll notice on this
one is the four and eight
ended at 66.7 and 65.54.
And they had a little bit
of gain in the 16 inches.
But we used four
gallons more to do that.
And the reality is as you
looked at that uptake,
it's really not taking
water from 16 inches.
So this is what
we also consider.
We don't want to over water.
I think of water as the new oil.
So we're constantly trying to
minimize the amount of water
but hit the zones
that we want to hit.
That's what's most important.
And we use that
by making sure we
know what FC is, tracking
each one of these irrigation.
And that's what we're
building our algorithms around
so that nio will
just do it for us.
It already is.
If you'd gone back to
one of those earlier--
I think it was actually the
dashboard-- it was recommending
five for 11.7 gallons.
I wouldn't go there, Doug.
But if you can now Doug
click on the open--
what's it called?
Yeah, that one, there you go.
So wait a second here.
And you'll see something.
And this is where it
really came to life for us.
This is a chart for the
last about a month that
shows the red is irrigations,
and the blue line
is showing where we went to.
And you'll notice there's great
symmetry amongst all of these.
This is exactly what
we're trying to do.
When you can start to manipulate
the water in the ground
and know what the
vines are taking up,
you have suddenly an opportunity
in the early part of the year,
I'll raise all those lines up.
I'll give it as much
water as it wants.
Why?
Because I'm trying
to grow the canopy.
I'll do that right
into early May.
At the end of May when
the fruit is about to set,
I'll actually bring
those lines down
because I'm trying to set
very small berries for a very
simple reason, the
flavor is in the skins.
So if the berries are
smaller, your fruitful skin
is a greater ratio to the pulp
of the berry of the juice.
And so by definition
or theory, you're
going to have more
flavorful grapes.
DOUG STANDLEY: Now
every one of you
are going to be able to go
out, and get drunk, and buy
a vineyard after this with
a lot more confidence.
But Philip, we've got to
reel this in a little bit
and get to the benefits.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: OK.
I'll do that.
DOUG STANDLEY: All right.
So let me close out this.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: So you're
going to take me out of that.
Anyway, suffice it to say, this
is a total game changer for us.
We have confidence
when we go to bed
that we know we've watered
what we need to water.
I don't wake up in the
middle of the night saying,
oh my God, have we watered this?
We know we have.
Nio helps us do that.
DOUG STANDLEY: OK Phil,
let's get to the meat of it.
Show me the money!
PHIL ASMUNDSON:
Show you the money.
Well, it's pretty
straightforward.
30% labor efficiency
because we have
them doing the right
things at the right time.
We're not guessing.
We have so much better
information about our vines
that we can direct our workforce
to do what we need them to do
when we need them to do that.
It's says 40%
reduction of water.
That's my guesstimate
for over the year.
And in June it was well
over 50% in terms of gallons
applied in 2018 versus 2017.
And up to about
a million gallons
will be saved this
year at Deep Sky.
And remember, this is a
small, 20-acre vineyard.
Now Doug, I think you have some
pretty interesting numbers.
DOUG STANDLEY: Yeah,
so take this notion.
A 15-acre vineyard
in Willcox, Arizona
saved a million
gallons of water.
There 18 and 1/2 billion
acres under plant worldwide
of viticulture.
If we got one-seventh of
these results worldwide,
that's 185 billion gallons
of water that could be saved.
Now, as I mentioned earlier,
coincidentally, farming
wastes about 60% of the
water that it's provided.
Philip is running
50% to 60% savings.
So the value of
instrumentation--
think of agriculture
as a metaphor
to many, many other markets,
and the value of connectivity,
and frankly, a proper platform.
So do you want to wrap this up?
PHIL ASMUNDSON: Yep, sure.
And those last two, crop
efficiency and price lift,
I look at those
together a little bit.
And this is really
all about quality.
At the end of the
day, everyone wants
to know how much
water we're saving.
And we are saving
a lot of water.
But I would say it's
not about saving water
as much it's about using
the right amount of water.
But if you use the right amount,
you will definitely save.
But it's also about
quality of fruit.
Quality of fruit definitely
yields higher quality wine.
We like to say 80% of the
wine is grown in the field.
And we're actually seeing that.
And quality is a
subjective thing.
You can guess at it.
You can look at it.
But you can taste it.
You can get the tannins.
You can get the ripeness
of the fruit, the fruit
flavors, and all that.
But I'd rather look
at my customers
because we don't keep
all of our fruit.
We sell a little
less than half of it.
And we have three main buyers.
Every one of those buyers now
puts on their label something
called "Vineyard Designation."
And their bottles, even though
it will say name of winery,
it'll say Deep Sky Vineyard
right there on the label
as well.
They're doing that
because we've become
known for higher quality fruit.
And just putting our
name on their bottles
lifts their ability to sell it
for a greater amount of money.
To me, that's the real kicker
to me because it really is--
our customers are
telling us your quality
is better, which has allowed
us to lift our prices.
None of them are here.
But it's going up
next year as well
because we're really excited
about our crop this year.
One last thing to look at,
75% lower cost of human error.
That was real.
We had people not showing up.
We live in Marana, Arizona.
This is in Willcox, Arizona.
We had one month
where the guy told us,
oh yeah, water, and
water, and water.
And we got our electric
bill, it was about $20.
You couldn't run that pump
for three or four hours
without it being 20 bucks.
And the guy just hadn't done it.
And we couldn't be
there all the time,
but we needed to
have visibility.
We took a cruise in
Alaska last year.
We were we were
monitoring that vineyard
during the entire
cruise, putting on water,
looking at needs of
water, all of that,
all from a ship somewhere
in a fjord in Alaska.
With that Doug,
turn it over to you.
DOUG STANDLEY: So the road
map and our progress to date
is, one tip is, again, if you
avoid the overthinking, the
how, but look for
a really quick win.
Now in this case,
the quick win was
having Phillip stop calling
me screaming about his wife
having to drive two hours to
check to see if the water was
on or not trusting the people
managing their vineyard.
So we got them the
confidence and the quick
win that they could remotely
manage his vineyard very,
very quickly.
The other thing
that we discovered
is that their entire
thesis about water usage
frankly was wrong.
They thought they
were distributing--
I forget how many gallons
it was now-- but literally,
it was one-fifth was
the actual amount.
Once we instrumented
the vineyard,
the water that was
getting to the plant
was a small percentage of
what they thought it was.
So that was a real quick win.
The first year we
connected the system,
got it stabilized, really
focused on the user experience,
made some adjustments to it.
Last year, we made
further modifications.
Went in and tuned
some algorithms.
Phil does as a lot of
back work, data crunching.
This year has been
extremely productive.
We're turning the ROI up.
He's transforming his business.
As he mentioned,
he's getting things
like vineyard designates.
So we're really
achieving the goals.
Frankly, none of
this is a surprise
from the original vision.
We had alignment that
this could happen.
But frankly, there's
a leap of faith.
So we focused hard
on the quick win.
And now we're really
seeing-- no pun intended--
the fruit of our effort.
Now, the super exciting
part, particularly
with the partnership
with Google,
is we're really looking
forward to next year,
refining this instrumentation
and computation model,
starting to incorporate ML both
from a data standpoint as well
as some video analytics.
We can talk more
about that offline.
We're getting short on time.
But frankly, this
project is now--
it's just too compelling.
We as a company are thinking
about how do we scale this.
So even though we're
going to stay horizontal,
we're now very focused on this.
The results are just undeniable.
Lastly for the tech audience,
we'll give you a quick flyby.
I think now this is
the second day of Next,
so you've seen slides that
looks something like this.
But this is really
an elegant marriage
between Google
handling the cloud
elements and our nio platform
handling everything below.
We're a distributed edge
processing platform.
So you see the data flow.
It my world, it starts
in the far right.
We have tightly wrapped IoT
core into our deployment model.
We use it.
It's functioning.
We use it in
everything we do now.
It's working beautifully.
Google's involving us in their
forward thinking about where
the product line goes.
And we're super
excited about that.
But remember now, this
is Willcox, Arizona.
Adam joked about, if you're
not at the bottom of the ocean.
But Willcox, Arizona
is about like being
in the bottom of the ocean.
It is a very, very remote place.
Our gross network pipe is
a 10.5 rural cell card.
That's it.
That's all we've got.
And we're very, very efficient
in network management.
We have numerous low-power
networks operating here.
But there's a lot going on.
So we run a local
network at the vineyard.
The vineyard's got to run.
It can't be dependent on
internet connectivity.
And then, of course, we
then filter and share
up to the cloud with Pub/Sub,
up through into Dataflow,
BigQuery.
And think of it as our
data warehouse there.
And of course, everything
is deployed with Kubernetes.
So numerous nodes
ranging from quad core
down to single-core
nodes because nio
is not just a
data-capturing platform.
This is a full control system.
This vineyard runs on auto mode.
it does not have to--
literally, nio will
make recommendations
and run the vineyard.
So we've got mobile tools.
We have a lots going on there.
We have recently introduced
a little bit of LoRa as well.
So that's super exciting.
But for me, it's just it's
a magnificent, elegant
collaboration between Google,
and us, and a fantastic
customer.
So it's just a win.
And on that, I think I'll
turn it back over to Adam.
ADAM MICHELSON: Sure, thanks.
Thanks Doug.
Thanks Phil.
Is this thing back on?
Yes.
So quick closing thoughts.
So to circle back to the ROI,
I hope that from the context--
so agriculture is a
major use case for IoT.
Manufacturing is
a major use case.
Smart home, medical, we're
seeing a number of verticals
begin to really
realize the benefits.
And it often starts in this way.
It's like, ugh, I don't want
to get up and drive two hours,
so in these boutique
way are disruptors.
It's what the big folks
are worried about.
But for the folks in the room
who are already big folks,
it's good not to start with
these huge, huge aspirations
with other data.
But start with something small.
Don't drive two hours,
make the CEO happy,
and then go from there.
But when looking for
ROI, the good mindset
is first thing
outside your company.
What's the macroeconomic trends?
In this case, it's water.
It's labor shortage.
What's happening
in the world that's
going to affect because we're
skating to the puck with IoT.
It's going to be a two
to a five-year journey,
so what's going to happen?
Competitive disruption, like
we were saying, x as a service.
So are your
competitors shifting?
Especially if you're
a manufacturer,
are they getting into the-- are
they becoming software vendors?
The minute you launch an app,
you're a software vendor.
And what's happening
there in your industry?
And then regulatory, we
didn't talk about here.
But we see a lot of
regulatory pressure.
And where that comes in,
IoT is a great release valve
because IoT provides
a lot of transparency.
So rather than having
auditors, having expenses
to deal with regulation,
IoT can deal with it.
So just some
macroeconomic trends,
I'm sure you can think of more.
After that, you think
of your internals
like the chart we
went through before.
Internally-focused, where
can we find revenue, get
as many tick marks as you can?
Direct revenue first,
indirect second, and see
if your thesis is achieved.
It can be achieved in a
very small way at first.
And lastly, no ROI, no pilot.
But basically, if you see
80% of your pilot effort--
and our pilot
effort is precious.
You all in the
audience can be doing
lots of things with your time.
The fact that so many hands
got raised around efforts
around IoT, we are all
responsible for exiting
pilot purgatory together
and finding this ROI.
It's not "Mission Impossible."
That's a movie reference.
PHIL ASMUNDSON: Well,
and to that point, Adam,
we talked about this.
And if a little vineyard
in Arizona of 20 acres
can get the kind of
results we've achieved--
and it wasn't easy.
There were some fits and starts.
But if we can do it, I can
only imagine the impact
you guys can make on
your companies, which
are much larger and probably
have a much bigger apple
to take a bite out of the stuff.
ADAM MICHELSON: And so--
thanks.
And so quick thoughts
in terms of wrap up.
Obviously, we're in the
middle of Next here,
so we really
appreciate your time.
Given the number of hands
that went up around IoT,
we're really excited.
If you haven't seen
Google's IoT offering yet,
please check us out.
So we're over in Moscone South.
Please come over to our
booth and check it out.
And we'll show you IoT Core.
The niolab's folks
are there as well
if you want to talk about
other IoT solutions,
or if you're into agriculture,
or want to become a sommelier,
you can learn more
about the industry.
And we have a booth
over there as well.
And then do please check us
out at google/googlecloudiot
and learn more
about the solution.
And we'd obviously love to
hear your feedback as well.
Within the IoT group,
I'm on the product team.
I can tell you we're
very interested.
And we are very interested
to hear your feedback.
So you can find me or anyone
else from the product team
and just would love to hear
your use cases because we're
learning and growing together.
And we'd like to thank
you for your time.
Thanks Phil.
Thanks Doug.
Enjoy the rest of Next.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]